INSTRUCTOR: Hello visitors.
For this adventure
guide, you're going
to learn how to map your data.
I'm going to cover area
maps, symbol maps, heat maps,
map features, and one
of my favorite features
is to use images as
a non-geographic map
to plot your data points.
So let's first dive into the AG
maps overview start TWBX file.
You can see I've got
several sheets that we're
going to cover, and I want to
talk about maps in general.
It's one of the most
powerful features in Tableau.
And maps can show a lot of
data and they're very visual.
It's incredibly
tempting that whenever
you have geographic data
that you want to map it.
But I first want you
to pause and think,
is this helping or
hindering my purpose,
and helping or hindering
my audience, OK.
So maps aren't always
the best choice depending
on what your purpose,
what your audience is.
And let's take a couple look.
Let's take a look at these
examples that I have here.
This first one is a typical
field map in Tableau.
I'm showing the lower 48,
missing Alaska and Hawaii,
just to fill the whole view up.
And you can see that some
of sales is on color,
and it's showing the
various states here.
We can see that the darker
states are showing that there
are larger amounts of sales,
and the lighter color states
are lower.
And clearly you can see that
California is the darkest color.
And then maybe there's New
York, maybe Texas, maybe Oregon.
Now, while you do have tooltips,
if your question is, which
are the top states
in sales, then
this would be very difficult to
maybe uncover those top five.
I might be pretty good
at guessing those.
But when it comes to
this middle region,
these all seem like
the same color,
so this would be very difficult.
Now you can modify
these color ranges.
You can create more
steps and so forth.
But what I would like
for you to consider
is maybe there's a different
chart type that would be better.
And that is the workhorse
of the bar chart.
So here I've got the
bar chart alphabetized.
I'm actually going to click
on the third sheet here
to show that they're ordered
and they're in descending order.
So I can quickly see that
California, New York, Texas,
Washington, and Pennsylvania
are those top five
states that really lead out.
Now, I might be
able to come down
and say, oh, look at Oregon
and Nevada are very close.
And I wouldn't be able to see
that necessarily on the state.
I can also flip this
to see the descending,
to see that North Dakota, West
Virginia, Maine, South Dakota,
and Wyoming are my lowest five.
And so different charts can
help answer different questions.
And so just be aware of that.
For this next cheat,
I have a filled map,
and the fill is
based on profit now.
So I've got the range where blue
shows profit and then orange
is showing loss.
And again, you can quickly see
that Texas is at that loss.
And then there's some
other few states that
are in that same kind of area.
If I was going to put
that on a bar chart,
you can see this is
also a diverging bar
chart where I've
got my loss here
to my left, my
profit to the right.
I could also order that, and
have that in descending order.
But I want you to think
about where and how I might
use these geographic data in
this map chart versus the bar
chart.
So if I'm looking at
this data and trying
to uncover maybe
regional opportunities
or regional insights,
like the questions--
why is Illinois, Ohio, and
Pennsylvania doing so poorly,
whereas New York and Michigan
seem to be a bit stronger?
Is there something
in this region
that I can do to
improve profit overall?
Whereas in the bar
chart I might be looking
at more state
oriented, like, these
are the states that are
performing very well,
maybe we need to
give bonuses on them,
or pair them with states
that aren't doing as well.
So again, one of the things
that I might consider doing
is, depending on what
my conversation, who
my audience is,
and my purpose, I
might create a
dashboard that includes
both the geographic data
and the bar chart to answer
some of those questions.
But again, think
about your purpose.
Think about your audience.
Think about whether a map will
help or hinder your story.
So let's take a
look at area maps,
and you should have the AG
maps start topic's file open.
You'll see that there are these
five tabs underneath that we'll
be covering.
And maps are pretty
straightforward and easy
to make.
And I do want you to notice
here in the Data pane, some
of the icons that denote fields
that have map data in it.
So when we brought
in our data source,
Tableau automatically
assigns different types
to the data that's coming in.
So if it is some words,
they'll put string data,
and that's what
that a BC denotes.
If it looks like it's a date
they'll put a calendar icon.
And if it has a city,
state, or country,
then it will have
that Globe icon.
Now if you need to change
that say for instance,
you want you're trying to
visualize your city data,
but it's not coming
out correctly,
you can always click
on that dropdown menu
and go to the geographic
role, and then
ensure that City is selected
versus maybe an area code,
a country, a state, et cetera.
You might also have
a column in your data
that is a titled city,
state, or country,
but is not geographic data.
It could be a true or false.
It could be other kinds of
filters that you're using.
And in that case, you need to
go back in and change that data
type, so it's not geographic.
So just double check
and know that you
have that power to change that
roll type, that data type.
So, for this area map,
what we're going to do
is do the largest geographic
roll, which is country.
And you can do this by 2 ways.
You can drag that
Country into the view.
And I'm going to just delete
that, or take those off,
so that I can show you
the second way, which
is simply by double clicking.
Now what we have
here is actually--
let me go change this
to automatic first,
because what Tableau
will do initially
is to plot your
various countries.
And if you look at this, you'll
see that there are two measures.
One on columns-- you've got
the longitude on columns
and the latitude on rows.
Now if you have two
continuous measures, and ones
on columns and ones
on rows, it should
be similar to another
chart type that you
should be familiar with.
And what chart type do
you think that could be?
If you said scatter plot
you would be correct.
So this right here is
more of a simple map,
and we'll talk about
those in a moment.
We want to cover an area
map, and for an area map
we need to change
the way the view is.
And so we're going to move
from automatic to a map.
And now we're filling
in these areas,
and that's where the
area map comes in.
Now right now they're
all the same color,
except for a few countries
where we don't have any data.
And then those are grayed out.
Now we need to add in some
information and some measures
to begin to use this area map.
So let's go ahead and
put Profit onto color.
And now you can see
for this area map,
we've got Profit being blue and
then loss being that orange,
and I can see the different
countries that are doing well.
Now, if I've got gray it means
that I don't have data regarding
some of those countries.
It looks like I've got data
on, like Chad and other Sudan
and so forth, but I don't have
data on this particular country.
So just know that
area maps are really
great for showing broad data
strokes within the map feature.
And one of the
disadvantages is that you
can't get into the
level of detail
without really
cluttering up this map.
So very broad pictures are
really great for these field
or area maps.
And we're going to dive
into the other map types
here in a moment.
Let's go ahead and look at
the power of a symbol map
by going to this
particular sheet.
One way that we can
map geographic data
is using a symbol map.
So unlike a field or
area map, a symbol map
doesn't rely on a map in
the actual geographic area.
We don't have an
outline that we fill
in, instead, we use individual
symbols as the marks.
So this can be
useful because we can
overlay additional
information on top
of the geographic boundaries.
And so let's take a look
at how we can do that.
We can just double
click country again.
It looks like I've
got these large sizes,
so I'm going to just make these
smaller for you and for me
so we can see that.
Again, this is just
like a scatter plot
where we have the two measures--
the longitude and latitude.
And I've got all of my
marks placed appropriately
based on that, those
latitude and longitudes.
So we can modify
this by changing
the size as I did before.
And you can do that
by just increasing
that size, just like that.
I can also-- let me just
show the filter here--
I can change.
Actually, that's not the
filter I wanted to show.
So let me put a field.
Let me remove that filter,
and instead let me--
so let me instead put
on category on to color.
So we're going to add
in some information.
And by doing that, let
me just-- so right now
I could be on a circle
or what have you,
and have different colors.
But I can change that
marks to be a pie chart.
Now I'm not recommending this
as a good design practice.
What I'm trying to
show is how symbols
can be overlaid and be used.
So you'll notice, first
of all, that these circles
are in the center of
each of the countries.
Again, it's an overlay, so I can
actually change some of those
to be different types, different
sizes, different shapes here.
I can make them filled
in or not filled in.
But one of the mark types I want
to do is just do the pie chart.
So let's go ahead
and Zoom in on this,
so that we can see
what's going on.
I'm going to Zoom in
here in Central America,
and I'm going to increase
the size so we can see.
So here we see that all the
pie charts are exactly the same
because it's just showing these
three categories of furniture,
office supplies, and technology.
So we need to add a
measure onto that.
And what I want to do is
add Sales onto the angle.
Since I've got this
pie chart, let me
actually just increase this size
a bit more so we can see these.
And maybe I'll Zoom
in a little bit.
Let me come back just
Zoom in on this area here.
And so now we can begin to
see that different regions,
different countries have
different slices of the pie
chart.
So while this is not the best
design principle nor outcome,
I do want to share
with you and remind you
that symbol maps are a
bit different, because you
can overlay information
on top of that
and begin to show
additional insights.
So symbol maps, they
can be an excellent way
to visualize geographic data
in a different kind of way.
Now let's take a
look at heat maps,
and we will jump into
the Heat Map tab here.
And heat maps are awesome
because they can reveal patterns
or relative concentrations
that might otherwise
be hidden due to the
overlapping marks on a map.
And heat maps can also
be called density maps,
so those are interchangeably.
And they're most
effective when you're
working with a data set
containing many data points
in a small geographic area.
So that's what we're
going to do here.
We're going to actually use
this hailstorm-damage data that
was brought in.
And what I want you to do is you
can go ahead and double click
on Latitude and
Longitude, and you
should have a map that comes up
with Minnesota, Wisconsin, North
Dakota, South Dakota,
all on this space.
And what we're going to do is
just look at some Hail damage,
and determine if there
are some areas that have
higher density of Hail damage.
So the way that we'll
do that is we're
going to drag Street
Address on to the Detail.
Oops.
If it comes up with a warning
card, then just click Add All.
All members there.
So now you can see we've zoomed
in on the specific data where
the street address was given
for each one of these streets,
and you can see each one
of those street addresses.
And you can also see that we've
got some color added on to this.
So this was on density.
So if you're on
automatic, right now
it might be showing all blue.
What I want you to do
is drop down the menu
and then just go to the
very bottom and hit Density.
In this you can begin to
see that there is density.
Your color may
not be this color.
I may have already done this.
You might see some
orange to light.
This is where you would do
it in the color marks card.
But you can select density
multicolor light here,
and you can have it more
intense or less intense
depending on what
your purposes are.
So let's just do the
intensity around 50%.
You can change the opacity
of it, so make it clearer.
So if you're going to
overlay something on top
or underneath it, let's go
ahead and keep that to 100.
But you can begin to see that
this particular zone was heavily
damaged by Hail, more
so than other areas that
reported hail damage.
So we can add in more
information for the tooltip.
I can put in the neighborhood
on the tooltip here.
We can put the damage type on
the tooltip and the reported
date on the tooltip.
So now can begin to--
let's go ahead and
roll over to see that.
Looks like the Downtown
West neighborhood
was hit the hardest, OK.
So there are some
other neighborhoods
that had some, Lowry
Hill and Loring park,
but definitely Downtown
West was hit the hardest.
So this is how you're able to
create the density or heat map.
Remember, you still have
your longitude and latitude,
and what you need
is a data set that
has lots of marks that
overlay one another so
that you can create this chart
type to be more of a density.
All right.
We've looked at a few
different map and map types.
Let's look at some
of the features that
are available in Tableau.
Here on the map-features
sheet you'll
see a view of the lower 48.
And whenever you
have the map, you'll
see that there's
this tool bar that
comes up in the lower or
the upper left corner.
And it has a couple of
things you can Zoom in.
So if I click that,
I can Zoom in,
and I can release that by
clicking that Pin icon.
I can double click by zooming
in and zooming out, OK.
And Recentering that,
or I have the feature
where I have the ability
to drag and drop to Zoom.
You can return back.
I can also position things
and move things around.
I can also select items too.
OK, so if I wanted to select
maybe this Southern California
region, I can actually--
let me go back
and select that with the
Selection tool again.
And if I had say keep only, see
that there are 107 marks out
of 604, so if I had decide just
to keep those only or in that
case, it looks like I selected--
let me go back here, actually.
So let me go back.
Let me reselect this to
be this whole Baja region,
and I'm going to say 70.
And now that I've
excluded everything else,
now I have 70 marks.
What this does, it reduces
the load time for my data,
and so I can quickly
get to this data
or have this data in the
view, if I so choose.
Now notice what's happened
on the Filters shelf
here is that it's added a
filter called Inclusions.
And so if I want to return
back to my main full map,
I can't just push
this button anymore.
That's No longer an option.
I have to remove this
filter from the map.
And then I can select that,
and I can come back here.
So I could say, OK, I'm just
going to focus on the Southern
region here.
I'm going to keep only those.
And now I've got
that as a filter.
I can remove that to get back.
So a couple other features
that you should just
be aware of within
maps is that you
can select the Dropdown menu
of maps and click Map options.
When you do that, you can also
right click this on the map box
that comes up.
You can show map search,
show layer options,
show the view toolbar, allow pan
and zoom, and show map scale.
So let's just pretend that I
am interested in let's go back
to this Baja region here.
Actually, let's Zoom in on that.
And versus excluding those
67 marks or what have you,
I want to pin those, OK.
So in order to pin those,
I go to my app Map options.
And I don't want to
show the view Toolbar.
I want to remove that, so that
I can't let my user change that.
So now that I've
done that, oops.
Let's see.
Got the Toolbar selected
still, so I'll deselect the Pan
and Zoom as well.
So then I'll close that out.
And now, I can't do anything--
I can't change, I
can't go and look
at Utah's or
Maine's information,
but I still have it available.
It's all of the marks.
But now I've just pinned it.
I don't have it as a filter.
Now to get back, I just
need to select those
and then I can reselect that.
The other feature under
the Map Options is Layers.
And that will pull up a dialog
box here in the left-hand side.
And you can see that there are
lots of layers to play with.
You can add in the Base,
Terrain, Coastline, et cetera.
You can also choose different
map varieties here with normal,
dark, you can add streets.
So I would definitely
explore this and especially
as you're creating maps--
ways that you feel like
would enhance your story.
And you can see here that there
are all different kinds of map
layers here.
You also have some
data that Tableau
has that you might be
interested in using,
perhaps in your project where
you could add in US households.
And so now it's giving that
information based on State.
And you can do County zip code.
I believe this is the 2018.
So this is not the
newest census data.
So if you want to
have more recent data,
you'd have to bring
that in yourself.
But you could leverage this
and use that particular.
I'm going to do the four corner
states kind of area here.
And you can begin to
see how households
with this amount of individuals
reflect in the color choices
here.
So there's lots of
different things
that you can do within States.
Just remember that
within the map toolbar,
you have the ability to
pin it and to unpin it,
that you have filtering that you
also have the map layers and map
options, and you
have your map legend,
which is here to the right.
So lots to explore when
it comes to customizing
map and their
features, and I hope
that you'll have a chance to
do that in future projects.
The last area I want to
cover in this adventure guide
are images and
plots, and something
that I feel that many of you
might be interested in using
in your own projects.
So let's go to this
final sheet in Tableau,
and you can map your data
onto a custom image, or map,
or other background.
And you might consider
doing a football field,
whether that be American or
what the other part of the world
calls in terms of
football or basketball,
or you could do grocery
aisles or all sorts
of different kinds of images
and maps to plot your data.
But remember, you can
do this with any image.
And so let's click on the
conference room data here.
So you can see room name,
room number, phone number,
virtual capacity, et cetera.
And we want to click on--
let's see the right data.
So make sure that you're on
this particular data field.
Let's move x onto
columns and y onto rows.
So x onto columns
and y onto rows.
OK, so this data
that I've created
it's actually in
an Excel worksheet,
and I've provided
that worksheet if you
want to take a look at it.
But now I've got one mark
on this scatter plot.
Remember that at the core you
have symbol maps that are really
scatter plots.
And so I'm plotting this
singular data right here.
And you should
see a single mark.
And let's do a few
formatting things.
I'm going to change this
to be entire view here.
So then let's click
on the map, and we are
going to do background images.
OK, so we're going
to go ahead and just
click on this my Clean Data.
That was the original
source that I had,
but you should have this
dialog box that comes up.
And this is where
I'm going to show you
how to place an image
into your Tableau file.
All right.
So what we want
to do is-- this is
where you can control all
the images that you'll
have in your view.
If you so choose you,
can edit remove them.
We're going to add an image.
And for this, what we'll
do is we'll browse.
And you should
have this somewhere
on your desktop downloaded.
And the file that you're going
to use is the office layout,
and I've given the
dimensions there.
And also notice it's a PNG file.
I found those to be the
very best file types when
bringing them into Tableau.
But you'll see here I have
the dimensions of 627 pixels
by 673 pixels.
Now, this is
important because when
you're bringing in
your images, it's
important to know
either their dimensions
or you're going to set their
dimensions by-- you could do 100
by 100, and then you could
plot 50 by 25 or what have you.
So you are plotting your
points specifically,
but I'm going to use what
my actual dimensions are.
So the conference coordinates
I'm actually going to put down
is--
I'm going to put in
right here on the right.
I'll do the 627.
And then with the
top, we'll do 673.
All right.
So after doing that
so the 0, 0 just
so you know, that is
going to be right here,
that I want this to be my 0, 0.
And then these are my dimensions
out based upon my pixels
that I've created, and I created
this image in Illustrator.
So I'm going to go
ahead and click OK.
And then I'm going
to click OK here.
OK, so I'll just click OK here.
Now one of the things you see
is there's a lot going on.
We're going to clean some
of this up right now.
So I'm going to just
right-click on my axis
and remove the show header.
Click on that axis,
remove the show header.
And now you see this image
is really small compared
to this dot right here.
As soon as I take room name
and place that on detail,
you'll see that has now
resolved itself, OK.
So Here we can see that now in
my file, if you look at my data
source, you'll be able to
see that these numbers, these
coordinates, these xy
coordinates match along
this axis.
So you can see here I've got the
room name is called Buttercup.
These are all based
on sweet treats.
And the x is 35
and the y is 633.
And so they've been plotted
against this background image
that I have just inserted, OK.
Now I could do a
few things on here,
just like I've done before,
is I can change the mark type
and I could change
it to be circle.
So I can change that
to be a solid circle.
I can also change the
room capacity or the view
by doing the room capacity
and put that on Color.
OK, so now I've got
different colors
showing different
room capacities here.
I can change all sorts of
things within this view.
Again, remember this is overlaid
on top of the map background,
or this image background here.
So one of the things
I wanted to show you
is that there is
one null value here.
There's one piece of my data
that doesn't have a coordinate.
So if I go into my
data source here
and I click on the conference
room data, you'll notice that--
oops, I can't click on
that conference room data.
You'll notice that
here in the Almond Joy,
there are two nulls because I
don't have the xy coordinate.
So I want to show you how
you can get that in Tableau,
which is a pretty cool feature.
So say we want to add
in the coordinates
for this particular
conference room.
What I'll need to
do is just right
click here in the view area,
and then select Annotate.
So we're going to annotate
a mark-- excuse me, point,
I meant to say that.
And then here you can see
we've got the x and y,
so I'm going to just
go ahead and click OK.
And you can see here I've
got the xy coordinates
for this particular mark,
but I can select that.
And then I can change
that by putting it
right here, which now I can
see that particular xy is
365 by 210.
So what you need to do is to
go into the Excel worksheet,
to your actual
data, and you need
to put in those
new xy coordinates.
So x is 365, so I
would type in 365.
And then y is 210.
So now I have found that data
for the Almond Joy conference
room, and now I can save that.
So Control-S, or
Command-S on a Mac.
And then I can go
into my data, and I
can update my data just by
hitting this little Update
icon here.
And then it will
take a few moments,
my computer is slower
when I'm also recording.
So you might also have this
processing request dialog box
as it goes and finds the data.
And now it's updated.
So we can look at
that here in the data.
I should-- oh, why
am I not seeing that?
Let's see.
Hopefully it's
connected to the right--
Excel sheet and not
something else on my--
just double check
I've saved that.
So I was having some
data connection problems,
so I actually had to re-add
this in instead of refreshing.
So I'm not quite sure.
And hopefully you're not having
that problem on your end.
But if you are, you may
need to delete and then add
that conference
room data back in.
You should be able to
just hit the Refresh.
My connections were off.
But in any event, if I go
back to the images now,
actually I can look in
the data source itself.
And you can see now that that
X, Y coordinate has been added,
and then also in the
images that has refreshed,
and you can see that
Almond Joy has been added,
and there's no
longer a null value.
So to remove that I can just
right click that and Remove
that annotation.
It's no longer there.
But I could find any kind
of coordinates anywhere
on this map.
So a way to work back is
you might bring in an image
and then begin to
place those coordinates
wherever you see fit.
So hopefully this
adventure guide
has given you a window into the
many capabilities of the map
features within Tableau,
and I look forward
to seeing you apply
them in your project.